so you have quite a bit of experience
first of all
to start starting a company yourself but
also i saw maybe you can correct me but
you
you have quite quite a bit of knowledge
of um
just in general the startup experience
of building companies
you've interacted with people if is
there
is there advice that you can give to
somebody
to a founder co-founder who wants to
launch and
grow a new company and do something
big and impactful in this world
yes i would say you know
like i mentioned earlier but make sure
the vision is something that you know
will get you out of bed in the morning
and
and will get and that you can rally
other people
around you to to achieve uh
because i see a lot of folks that
sort of cared about something or saw a
window of opportunity to do something
and you know startups are hard and and
more often than not
just being opportunistic isn't going to
be enough to make it through
all the really crappy um things that are
going to happen
but the vision just helps you
psychologically to carry through the
hardships
for you and the team yeah you and the
team yeah exactly
to kind of younger people interested in
getting into entrepreneurship
i would say you know stay as close to
like first
principles and and fundamentals as you
can for as long as you can
because really understanding the
problems you know if it's something
scientific or hardware related or
even if it's not but having a deep
understanding of
of the problem and the customers and
what people care about and
how to move something forward is more
important than
taking all of the entrepreneurship
classes
in undergrad so being able to think
deeply yeah yeah
exactly yeah have you been surprised
about how much like pivoting is involved
like basically rethinking what you
thought initially would be the right
direction
to go or is there if you think deeply
enough
that you can stick in the same direction
for long enough
so our you know our guiding
star hasn't changed at all um so that's
been pretty
consistent but we within that we flip
flop on
so many things um all the time and you
know to give you one example it's
do you stop and build a first
product that's well suited to
maybe a smaller less exciting segment of
the market
or do you stay head down and focus
on you know the big swing and trying to
hit it out of the park right away
and we've flip-flopped between that and
there's not a
blanket answer and there are a lot of
factors but
um that's a hard one and i think one
one other piece for the aspiring founder
spending a lot of time and effort on the
culture and people peace is so important
and is always
an afterthought and something that
i haven't really seen like the founders
or
or executives at companies purposefully
carve out time and
and acknowledge that yes this is going
to take
a lot of my time and resources and then
but you see them after the fact trying
to repair
the you know bro culture or whatever
else is broken at the company
and i think that it's starting to change
um but just to be aware of it from the
beginning
is important right i guess it should be
part of the vision of what kind of place
you want to create
or what kind of like
human beings yeah exactly like you can't
wait
five ten years and then just slap an hr
person on to trying to fix it like it
has to be thoughtful from the beginning
yeah don't get me started on hr people
uh don't leave hr to hr people but i'll
just leave it at that you didn't say
that i said it
okay uh yeah hr's
actual hr is really important this
is so myself yes so culture so important
yeah and then i also was surprised
like i thought you could say here will
be our culture and our values and that
it was kind of distinct from who
i and my co-founder were as people and i
was like no that's not how that works
we just kind of like ooze out our
behaviors and then the company grows
around that so you have to do a lot of
like introspection and self work
to not end up with a shitty culture it's
kind of a it's
a it's a relationship but as opposed to
a relationship with two people it's
relationship with many people
yeah and you yeah you communicate so
much indirectly
by who you are you have to be yes you
have to live it
yeah uh as somebody
i think about this a lot because
generally i'm full of love and all those
kinds of things
but like i also get like really
passionate and
when i see somebody in in the context of
work
especially when i see somebody who i
know can do a much better job
and they don't do a great job i can lose
my [ __ ]
in a way that's like steve jobsian
and you have to think about exactly the
right way to lose your [ __ ] if you're
going to
or if at all you have to really think
through that because it sends a big
signal
uh you know sometimes that's okay like
if you do deliberately
like if you're going to do it
deliberately if you're going to say like
i'm going to be the kind of person that
allows this
and pays the cost of it but you can't
just think it's not going to have a cost
yes this was like the first thing i
worked on with my leadership coach was
to how not to just snap
people when they were being an idiot and
um first i got really good at
apologizing that was the first step
because it
was going to take longer to fix
brilliant behavior and then
she i've got i'm actually a lot better
at it now and it started with things
she's like every time
you walk through a doorway think you
know
calm and take breaths before responding
and there were all sorts of these little
things we did and
it was mostly just changing the habit
yeah
yeah oh boy it's a long road
you